so I get asked all the time what type of  flannel do I wear I wear Fair Day the  reason I wear them is a couple reasons  one is that they're really stretchy and  that's because I have an odd shape  beyond that in this rainbow of colors  that I have is that there's four  temperature settings temperature setting  one is I'm not wearing it two is that  I'm wearing it open with the sleeves up  which is the coolest setting the next  warmest is I can roll it down and still  wear it open and then finally the  hottest setting is I can button this all  the way up and now I've actually got  more of like a winter Vibe and that way  if I can go between Outside Inside and  so that is why I wear these shirts check  out my only capture that Layla got me  for our anniversary because it's  hilarious she's the best